all right now that the fireworks on
Capitol Hill today where Marjorie tell a
green humiliated bang Bang's
ex-boyfriend little Eric swalwell during
a hearing take a look at this
Mr secretary do you believe that all of
us have a responsibility to elevate our
rhetoric and to denounce anti-Semitism
and anti-police rhetoric in this country
so that Jewish Americans and police
officers can be safer
Congressman I do thank you and I yield
back
the gentleman yields and now I recognize
the gentlelady from Georgia Miss Green
that was quite entertaining from someone
that had a sexual relationship with a
Chinese spy and everyone knows it but
they move to take our words down the
gentleman will state the words that he
wishes taken down
everything that the gentlelady from
Georgia has said no you need to be more
specific accusations of an affair with a
Chinese spy
those are engaging in personalities
and they those words should be taken
down and the gentlelady should not be
able to speak anymore in this hearing
the chair recognizes the gentlelady from
Georgia and asks if she would like to
retract those words
no I will not
[Applause]
who benefited from China here with the
very latest uh Revelations and he is
making a ton of progress uh his
investigation into the Biden family
Syndicate he is the chairman of the very
powerful important house oversight
government reform committee and that
would be James Comer welcome to the show
I'm going to give you the ball and let
you run with it we now have nine Biden
family members six additional members
now so nine in total that we know
benefited financially from the deals
that Hunter Biden was involved in Hunter
Biden implicates his own father and
complains that he has to give half his
income to Pops he complains about paying
for pops for pairs uh he we know he was
referred to as the big guy so my
question to you is this
now that we have all the Biden family
members implicated now that you now have
been able to follow the money and the
suspicious activity reports tell us
where we are in this investigation and
what is it what where are we now headed
because what you said to me on radio
this week was devastating for the bidens
yeah Sean as you know we went in to the
treasury uh assuming that there were
four or five Biden family members
involved in this Biden family influence
peddling scheme we assumed there were
about a dozen Banks we assumed there
were a certain number of suspicious
activity reports uh what we quickly
learned from going through the thousands
of pages of Bank violations that were
this family was involved in there are
nine Biden family members and Counting
Sean there are at least two others that
I would bet money on will be implicated
before long there are many more banks
that were involved there were many more
llc's that were involved this was a
family Enterprise but the LLC Sean they
don't appear to be legitimate businesses
their their sole purpose from what my
analysis is thus far is they were just
used to try to disguise or launder
however you want to describe it where
the source of the revenue was and and
the source was you know places like the
Chinese Communist party places in
countries that honestly have worse
reputations than than China and they
went to Great Lengths to try to hide the
fact that this money was coming in to
the bidens by by transferring it to many
accounts the banks picked up on this
that's why they filed Bank violations
and then they went directly into Biden
families members personal accounts it
wasn't for seed Capital like the Biden
lawyers are trying to claim and when
they talk about legitimate businesses
Sean I have yet to find a legitimate
business I found a lot of llc's we
continue to find more but you know Sean
you and I can form an LLC and call it
Hannity and comer energy that doesn't
mean we're in the energy business we
just have an LLC with the word energy in
it and we haven't found any legitimate
business by the way Hunter Biden himself
went on GMA and he was asked do you have
any experience in oil gas Coal Energy
nope nope nope nope do you have any
experience with Ukraine no why do you
think they paid all this money I don't
know and he goes and then the
interviewer says maybe because your
daddy was the VP in charge of Ukraine
policy and he goes probably so the
question is here we're talking about
some of our biggest geopolitical foes
we're talking about Russia we're talking
about China and you said over a dozen
countries how much money when we know
how much money in business the Biden
family did with hostile regimes and how
much money they put in their pocket at
the end of the day and my last question
is part of a long question is do you
believe the president of the United
States is compromised by these countries
that we know hate our guts
I'll answer the second question I don't
see how Joe Biden could not be
compromised I mean this these family
members aren't energy experts they
weren't on boards at least with barisma
Hunter actually sat on a board there are
no other boards that we can find that
these family members sat on certainly
not the the grandchildren and the nieces
and the nephews and the in-laws and
things like that and so what were they
doing why were they getting this much
money it all points back to Joe Biden
and we're going to continue until we get
the truth to the American people but I
can say this shot the walls are closing
in on the Biden family
we appreciate you being with us thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else